مشاهدينا اهلا بكم مجددا الى الخامسه
وننقل لكم هذه الصور التي يتم تداولها
للمنزل الذي تمت مداهمته من قبل القوات
الاردنيه تم تفكيك خليه ارهابيه متهمه
بالضلوع في مقتل الدلابيح وطبعا مداهمه
ادت الى مقتلي ثلاثه من ضباط وافراد القوه
اصابه ايضا خمسه اخرين ومقتل الارهاب الذي
اطلق النار حاله بدات
المداهمه طبعا كان هناك بيان للامن العام
الاردني تحدث فيه ايضا عن القاء القبض على
تسعه اخرين مشتبه بهم ايه تحدث عن اربعه
اشقاء للارهاب المقتول وثلاثه اخرين من
ابناء احدهم وايضا تحدث عن شخصين اخرين
كنا برفقه هؤلاء
والقوى الامنيه والامن العام الاردني تحدث
عن انه دبت بحوزتهم مجموعه من الاسلحه
الناريه كبيره من الذخيره ونشاهد من خلال
هذه الصور طلقات النار على الحيطان والتي
تدل على حجب المواجهه بين الجانبين